...
-Tu avais à peine 15 ans.
Tes cheveux portaient des rubans.
Tu habitais tout près,
du Grand Palais.
Je t'appelais le matin,
et ensemble, on prenait le train
pour aller...
au lycée.
Michèle, assis près de toi.
Moi, j'attendais la récré
pour aller au café,
boire un chocolat
et puis t'embrasser.
Un jour, tu as eu 17 ans.
Tes cheveux volaient dans le vent.
Et souvent tu chantais
"Yesterday".
Les jeudis après-midi,
on allait au cinéma gris
voir les films...
de Marilyn.
Michèle, un soir en décembre,
la neige tombait sur les toits.
Nous étions, toi et moi,
endormis ensemble
pour la première fois.
Le temps a passé doucement,
et déchu le prince charmant,
qui t'offrait des voyages
dans ses nuages.
On m'a dit que tu t'es mariée,
en avril, au printemps dernier,
que tu vis...
à Paris.
Michèle, c'est bien loin tout ça.
Les rues, les cafés joyeux,
même les trains de banlieue
se moquent de toi,
se moquent de moi.
Michèle, c'est bien loin tout ça.
Les rues, les cafés joyeux,
même les trains de banlieue
se moquent de toi,
se moquent de moi.
...
Se moquent de moi.